friendship where you did i'm about to
give you a compliment too steve
i was about to go give you a really
great throw it out anyways i'll could do
it anyway let me change face
let me change face okay
so it's so creepy um
here's another thing i love about you
and this is
and you just take it just take it okay
okay
is you know stand-up comedy
is something i started with in 1995
i signed up for open mic i'd never done
anything before
acted nothing i just walked off the
streets and signed up at a
open mic in san diego and
i started doing it i worked really i
went up
every night bombed for years
and i got to a point moved to la and i
did all the rigman roll
and all the things that you need to do
and i got to a place where oh [ __ ]
i can audition for shows now and i got
on the tonight show and i did all the
things right
and so you know i feel like i'm a
organic you know stand up sure
and you know as comics when we talk
right
we see actors and other people from
other fields right
crossover and do stand up right and it
takes a lot for us
to go to give that person it's rightful
credit
and go that person's to stand up now
because i know
thousands of people that actors and
other people that have crossed over and
i went
[ __ ] that guy that guy should not be
doing it but you're
the type of stand-up that you should be
doing it because you proved your worth
well thanks man i'll tell you why i say
that
it was one night you were at the store
or whatever you were talking with a
bunch of comics you were hanging out
when in my head i thought i did it
didn't
i was never it was not a question that
you shouldn't be there
you know i mean like i looked at you
like i looked at whitney cummings or any
of these other people like
oh cool steve's here my friend you know
a comic right
you know over you know a long time ago
when i saw you
staple your nut sack at the mint right
back in the day right
i wouldn't even fathom that i would even
accept that like there's a rare case you
are like that
obviously theo vaughn because theovonne
didn't come from
you know um a standup he had to
change or he had to reinvent himself
right and you did and i knew this also
when you invited me and ian over to your
house
because you're working on your first
special to give you notes and me
and you and i and i still talk about it
how
we respected that that you wanted our
you know
notes and your help with your special it
was like
you know um i just you know my hat's off
to you
you know i wasn't i was going to see
this earlier on the podcast than you
attacked me about this
and i literally thought to myself i'm
not going to even going to say this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
from this [ __ ] face then i decided to
[ __ ] do it anyway
because i really do mean that man all
right how do you feel about it i i
i super love you i super appreciate your
kind words
i i really really do i love that you
were willing to come over to
to check out this and if i recall
correctly it was like
i think it was like a week or two weeks
before i was actually gonna tape the
special
and i had you guys come over i asked you
to come over to uh
to view like the the last show i had
taped you know yeah what should i do
and you were like hey man maybe next
time why don't you
let's do this a little [ __ ] sooner
when it's not like next week yeah
like and and i also remember too that
uh i mean you're being very kind because
i wasn't ready to [ __ ] tape that
special
you know like oh you wish you hadn't
done it it wasn't that i wish that i
hadn't done it
it was just that you know like there
were
there was just there was a lot that just
you know i mean before where i was at
that time
it couldn't have come out any better but
where i was at that time
was very early in the process yeah and
here's something that i had a lot
i i have a